A few weeks ago, I met Emily, this wonderful elegant person
Our sons brought us together actually
Come here little dude. Can me and Miles have a play date today?
Do you drink? Does your kid drink? Maybe, I mean, it's never too early to start teaching them
I think you're joking, but great
Every time we do this I feel so high town
Wanna trade confessions?
No, no
Come on, what's the wildest thing you've ever done?
She's an enigma, my wife. You can get close to her but you can never quite reach her
Oh, she's like a beautiful ghost
Did you just take my picture?
Erase it. I guess I'm probably not the kind of person you're normally friends with
Oh, you do not want to be friends with me. Trust me
Stephanie I need your help. Are you okay? I'm fine, but I do need just a simple favor. Can you come over? Yeah
Five days ago Emily went missing
I warn you, you go poking around in her past, you're gonna find something that is terrifying
She was not a normal person like you or me
I've never seen such a beautiful girl want to be so invisible
I smell her Sean. I smell her perfume like a ghost. It's just you being paranoid
I saw my mom.
She told me to say hi to Stephanie
Were you aware that he took out an extra four million dollar life insurance policy on Emily before she disappeared?
People do terrible things for their own reasons. I thought you knew more than you were letting on
I wanna know your secret